oh
it was nice to be
okay
tricky
[Music]
[Music]
i
[Music]
um
did you take a while to get the video no
i mean first time
myself
um
yeah um
[Music]
yeah absolutely
what's up
well
what's the output
okay
hi guys
take care of it
thank you
all right
is that your camera in the middle where
it's a really tall one
no that's fine we all agree with our
bikes
is
[Music]
i think you're still
okay
yeah i mean the whole thing is above
this i think
i think yeah
[Music]
[Music]
it makes it
oh
okay
okay
uh
just set your camera up yourself just
you know what shots you eat
fancy losers
um
um
oh
oh
[Music]
your tip was already
i
um
[Music]
they will give us one
okay
[Music]
it is what it is and i'm taking my chest
here
i need to make sure i have a clean shirt
from you can you mine
thank you
this is
two minute warning
yo yeah all right
so
difficult
no thanks
um
hello
not the first time
okay
our personal
hello everyone good afternoon yesterday
the united states
witnessed a medical miracle the first
doses of a
covid vaccine were administered to
frontline workers across the country
the president promised a safe and
effective vaccine
in record time and president trump
delivered
earlier this year we heard from several
news outlets and so-called fact checks
that president trump would need quote a
miracle
to be right that was an nbc news article
we were told according to helpline
quote a vaccine will still take more
than a year to develop
usa today warned us that quote despite
medical researchers progress the vaccine
quote was more than a year
away and national geographic even told
us that achieving a vaccine within quote
a year to 18 months would be absolutely
unprecedented end quote these reports
deserve
their own fact check false
president trump has not only been the
optimist
hopeful to achieve a vaccine by year's
end he has also been a leader
through operation warp speed president
trump the businessman
and the president as the innovator has
succeeded
president trump directed military
logistics experts at the department of
defense
to partner with health experts at health
and human services to ensure prompt
delivery
of vaccines and equipment this includes
the appointment of four-star
general purna who oversees the global
supply chain and readiness for the
united states army
as operation warp speeds chief operating
officer
the trump administration supported
clinical trials by
working to enroll participants through
nih-funded covid protection networks
and provided funding and technical
support through the national institute
for allergy and infectious disease
and biomedical advanced research and
development authority
president trump also directed industrial
scale manufacturing of vaccines to take
place
at its own risk before knowing whether
these vaccines would be successful it
was a novel approach
indeed to vaccine development led by
president trump
the results of these historic
investments will benefit the american
people and will mark the beginning of
the end
of the pandemic as the first doses of
the vaccine are delivered and
administered
we urge all americans to continue to
wash your hands socially distance
wear a mask when you are unable to do so
we also encourage those at the state
level to improve the early
and aggressive use of monoclonal
antibody treatments especially
among vulnerable americans the trump
administration led the way
approving monoclonal antibody treatments
for outpatient use
issuing two emergency use authorizations
in november
additionally through hhs's office of the
assistant secretary for
preparedness and response monoclonal
antibody patient courses
have been allocated to all 50 states
together these steps can play a
significant role
changing the course of the virus thank
you to president trump and with that i
will take
questions now that the electoral college
has voted does the president
acknowledge that joe biden is the
president-elect doesn't have any
um the president is still involved in
ongoing litigation related to the
election uh yesterday's vote was one
step in the constitutional process so
i will leave that to him and refer you
to the campaign for more on that
litigation
reaction to uh leader mcconnell today
congratulating
joe biden and calling him the
president-elect i haven't gotten the
president's reaction to that yet but the
president
um again is pursuing ongoing litigation
would refer you to the campaign for
further litigation if
the votes have been certified if the
electoral college has voted there
doesn't seem to be a legal recourse at
this point
the campaign would have more specifics
for you on legal recourse but yesterday
was one step in the constitutional
process
leading up to the january 20th date in
the constitution
steve does the president plan to take
the vaccine and really do it in a public
way to inspire confidence among people
so the president currently at this
moment has said he is
absolutely open to taking the vaccine
he's been emphatic about that
uh to me privately and to you all
publicly
but he did recently recover from covid
um he has the continued protective
effects of the monoclonal antibody
cocktail that i mentioned
and he will receive the vaccine as soon
as his medical team determines its best
but
his priority is frontline workers those
in long-term care facilities and he
wants to make sure that the vulnerable
get
access first taking the vaccine set an
example for americans to give them
confidence
doctors uh dr bauchi as well as the
month of louisville said today
that they think president trump should
get the vaccine it is
a you know because for himself would be
to set an example
will he do that like why not do it just
to show americans that it's safe
because he also wants to show americans
that our priority are the most
most vulnerable there will be uh some
senior administration officials taking
it publicly to instill that confidence
it is very important
and the president uh no but you'll
you'll learn in the next few days who
that is um
who those individuals will be uh but
they will be taking it publicly to
instill confidence the president wants
to send
a parallel message which is you know our
long-term care facility residents and
our frontline workers
are paramount and importance and he
wants to set an example in that regard
i absolutely would be open to taking the
vaccine as
has been reported as i shared with some
of you yesterday
the white house it will be a very
limited group of people
who have access to it initially the
president's tweet indicated that
the white house should receive it at a
later date to again prioritize
the most vulnerable but some career
staff national security staff for the
purposes of continuity of government
will have access in addition to a very
small group of senior administration
officials for the purpose of instilling
public confidence he has said
that he thinks americans will be able to
take it if they want to take it you're
saying he's hoping
to taking it is he going to encourage
americans to take it or is he going to
leave it up
to americans does he think americans
should get this shot absolutely look
these are
vaccines that he oversaw the development
of he has great confidence in he wants
to see
all americans get this vaccine and he
wants to see the most vulnerable among
us get it first but absolutely he will
be encouraging
uh encouraging americans to take this
yeah
do you know when specifically when the
president will veto the national defense
authorization act when he's going to
send the paperwork over
and why would he veto that given the
fact that passed on veto
majorities in congress so he still does
plan
to veto the ndaa don't have a timeline
for you on that but he does plan to veto
it
um he wants to make every effort to
protect our military men and women
and will prioritize military funding in
the big omnibus bill but
um he also has other important
priorities and i should say problems
with the ndaa beyond just the absence of
section 230 repeal
um and beyond the inclusion of the
warren amendment um one of the
provisions of concern is troop
provisions about troop withdrawal and
deployment in afghanistan south korea
and germany and so there are a number of
provisions that um
china but no republicans seem to agree
with on that why does he think the bill
is bad on china
so by not including a section 230 repeal
what you're in effect allowing um is
twitter to
continue to not censor chinese
propaganda recently there was a
tweet by the u.s the chinese embassy in
the united states about
the xinjiang province and allowing all
citizens
to enjoy the same rights including
freedom of religion that clearly is not
the case as the uyghurs have been
absolutely tortured in that province
there was another tweet that they
allowed about the
virus originating in wuhan they said it
was not it did not originate wuhan that
obviously is chinese
disinformation uh and the president's
priority is to ensure that that isn't
permitted
yes um did leader mcconnell give the
president a heads up that he was gonna
talk about biden on the floor today um
i'm not sure if he had any call with him
prior to making that statement okay is
secretary mnuchin
or uh chief meadows going to be involved
in the bipartisan
meeting that's happening on the hill
today four o'clock about covert relief
i believe it's just um congressional
leaders meeting but i'll get back to you
if there is a white house presence there
but what i can tell you is that the
white house has had
a continuous presence in the stimulus
talks leading
on this um from for months uh trying to
get this phase four
passed and uh when i spoke with the
chief about this again this morning um
he noted that nancy pelosi has really
been standing in the way of the deal
going back prior to the election when
she was anti-stimulus checks something
the president
has been vocal about wanting and then
after the election according to her
quote she can now support these checks
because of a quote new president was
or her words uh which is appalling to
think that politics was playing into the
copic relief for the american people
and she stood against liability
protection this is protection for our
small businesses so that
they're not held liable for coveted
incidences through no fault of their own
and she's really playing up to the trial
lawyers
on an opposing liability protection
which should be something that's just
mere common sense
question about confirmations of biden's
cabinet picks uh
president trump had the benefit of the
senate starting hearings and starting
the process before he was inaugurated in
january
of 2017. does the president oppose
the senate taking up uh joe biden's
nominees before
the inauguration i think that's a
hypothetical um and you know he won't
get ahead of
that activity actually happening but he
has taken all statutory
requirements um necessary to either
ensure a smooth power
yes thanks bailey given the success of
operation warp speed
why hasn't president trump been more
visible
during this initial vaccine rollout
you're the vice president
in indiana today uh where's president
trump
uh president trump's been hard at work
on covid behind the scenes just because
you don't see him at the podium every
day
doesn't mean that he's not aggressively
pursuing actions on behalf of the
american people
he's briefed on kobit regularly and i'm
here speaking with you guys others
are out communicating this information
yeah could you comment
on the russian hackers breaching several
federal
agencies how how how serious was this
breach and is the trump administration
considering retaliating look the u.s
government we're aware
of all of these reports we're taking all
necessary steps to identify and remedy
any possible issues related to the
situation
as one step in that process cisa has
issued an emergency
directive on sunday night for all
federal civilian agencies to review
their networks for indicators of
compromise
and disconnect or to power down solar
winds orion products
immediately uh so we are taking a hard
look on this and obviously
take any sort of cyber hacks very
seriously and just one more question on
russia
since uh russian president vladimir
putin has
congratulated president-elect joe biden
any any comment on that
from the russian president um no comment
on that i'll leave it to the president
to react to that has he spoken to
president trump
not that i'm aware uh let's see
david does the president intend to
run for election in 2024 and would you
like to be part of that campaign
i will leave that to the president but
he's still pursuing on ongoing
litigation at the moment
for this election yes
thanks president trump supported the
texas lawsuit
at the supreme court and a lawsuit that
president-elect biden
called an assault on democracy how is it
not
is it not anti-democratic to try to
nullify 20 million votes
i think pursuing legitimate litigation
through the judicial system is in no way
assaulting democracy in fact it's
it's using democrat institutions in the
manner uh they are to be used
to pursue pursue legitimate claims with
sworn affidavits um
and additional evidence but i do think
what is an assault on democracy
are the four investigations into
president trump over russia collusion
that turned up
nothing i mean moeller alone you had 19
lawyers 40 fbi agents 2800
subpoenas 500 search warrants millions
of taxpayer dollars all to find
no collusion and the investigation into
president trump
began far before he was even elected
president of the united states um and
his intel briefings um
in the transition period were even
weaponized against him on an insurance
policy from peter strzok
uh was put in place against this
president prior to him being elected
that is what is an assault
on democracy blake thanks hayley um i
want to ask you about focus relief
negotiations but just to hone down
on what was asked about the vaccine yes
or no we should expect to see president
trump
take a coronavirus vaccine before
january 20th and do so on camera he will
take it um when his when health experts
and his white house doctor
um ask him to do so and says it's the
appropriate time he is very open to
taking this
but also wants to prioritize our
frontline workers since you brought up
the vaccine before you get to your next
question one thing i do
uh want to make clear is that there are
2.9 million
doses of the pfizer vaccine that have
gone out in 21 days
there will be an additional 2.9 million
of those doses because of course the
pfizer vaccine is two doses
um and there are going to be rolling
updates and shipments um of the vaccines
of course we've secured millions in
advance
and this friday there will be four
million pfizer
vaccines going out we are hopeful that
moderna gets approved the f
fda said that the data looks good we're
waiting for that eua
so hopefully there will be that eua and
then an additional six million madeira
doses out next week so
10 million doses out next week and i
want to emphasize just stepping back
from a macro perspective because it is
so impressive
uh what this president did making these
agreements in advance
and he secured not just tens of millions
of doses but in fact
hundreds of millions uh there's the 100
million with pfizer there's 100 million
with moderna
uh we've secured another 100 million
from moderna we're hopeful um that we
will get
an additional 100 million from pfizer i
think um we will
uh and then johnson and johnson is
nearing the end of its phase three
clinical trial that's another 100
million doses secured
with hundreds of millions doses more if
needed and then astrazeneca
which is in phase 3 clinical trial 300
million doses secured so it's a really
impressive achievement what this
president has done but what's your next
question
negotiations um so there's this meeting
this afternoon
the big four up on the hill we're told
by the way that secretary mnuchin will
be there
if if the big four if the treasury
secretary
are able to come to some sort of a deal
would president trump
sign off on it or does he have specific
asks specific red lines that have to be
in any sort of deal
i think we'll wait to see uh what that
deal looks like he's um
said that he would really like to see
those stimulus checks in there
but his priority at the end of the day
is getting relief to the american people
we're hopeful there will be
some sort of agreement but i would note
that we've been the party that's been
flexible we've been the party that's
said hey standalone ppp that's funding
for small businesses
and funding for businesses generally to
go to pay their employees
uh we've had a standalone bill that we
supported there we had a stand-alone a
standalone unemployment insurance bill
so we've been the party that's been
flexible
clear if there is a deal that doesn't
have direct payments the president would
support it or not
i i'm not going to say if that's a red
line or not i won't get ahead of the
negotiations but i'll just say that we
are hopeful there is a deal there that
the president
uh can then look at and support uh yes
tavern
uh white house have any comment on
bailey the security director
who had his leg amputated yeah our um
heart goes out to his family they've
asked for privacy
um and he is recovering from what i
understand we're very pleased
to see that but he and his family will
be in our prayers has the president had
a chance to speak
um i'm not sure if the president's had a
private conversation with him nor would
i confirm any any private conversation
that he did have
thank you thank you for doing this over
the weekend a statue of mahatma gandhi
was desecrated by some protesters in
downtown d.c
this is for the second time this has
happened uh
i will have to have your comments on
that yeah um it's
terrible um no statue or memorial should
be desecrated and certainly not
one uh like that of gandhi who really
fought for the values
that america represents of peace justice
and freedom so that desecration
is appalling to see it's appalling that
it's happened more than once and we
believe
uh the reputation of mahatma gandhi
should be respected
especially here in america's capital one
more
sure does the president believe that the
democracy in the united states
and the threat and based on the streets
what are the electoral reforms he wants
to push
in this country what was the first part
of your question i couldn't the
president believes that democracy united
states is under threat
that democracy is under threat um he
believes that he
certainly was under assault uh when it
comes to the investigations into his
administration
the mueller probe the unfortunate way
that our fbi
uh was mishandled by folks like andy
mccabe
uh by folks like jim comey um and
weaponized in a political way
uh against his candidacy and then
against his his presidency
and from county michigan i'd have to
refer you
as the campaign on anything regarding
the election
this is as far as the 2018 um
executive order on election interference
has he received a report yet
and when he does receive it is any of
that going to be
available for the public to look at i am
not aware of any report that he's
received
to that end thank you
just want an update statement on iran
especially in light of the just signed
israel morocco deal where does the white
house see that iran standing in the
middle east
now especially what is the current
assessment from the white house
with regards to iran standing in the
middle east as you continue to
sign middle east deals are they going to
strengthen is it weakening
what is the current white house
assessment on iran yes
the region increasingly comes together
through these peace deals which um
senior advisor jared kushner avi
berkowitz and others
national security advisor robert o'brien
deserve a ton of credit for it's
remarkable
but as the region continues to come
together our maximum pressure campaign
continues to be effective iran is
increasingly isolated
and weakened and when president trump
came into office you know that the
region was an extreme turmoil
isis had a caliphate and iran's proxies
were wreaking havoc
since taking office president trump has
worked to rebuild trust with our
regional partners
and identify their shared interests and
unlike the previous administration which
gave
iran a piles of cash and a a deal with a
sunset provision that would have allowed
them to get nuclear weapons
uh this president has isolated iran and
he's done it through four peace deals
which is four more than his
predecessor but it's unfortunate that it
doesn't give much coverage
in the mainstream media uh but i guess
we shouldn't be surprised because in the
last 24-48 hours there have been quite a
few stories that
not gotten a ton of coverage in the
mainstream media
as former white house press secretary
ari fleischer said
bias is often found in stories the press
does not
cover and last week we found out that
democrat congressman eric swalwell
was infiltrated by an alleged chinese
spy
the spy cozied up to swalwell raised
funds for his 2014 campaign
and even planted an intern in his office
and that relationship continued until
the fbi briefed him
in 2015 and that was some very good
reporting done by axios
but after entangling with this spy for
years swalwell hypocritically went on to
be one of the lead
instigators of the russia collusion
hooks in the impeachment
sham swalwell wrote this on his
congressional webpage
president trump and his team are
directly and indirectly tied to russia
that was not true he then said in
september of 2020 the president has a
compromised relationship with russia
untrue april of 2019 he said president
trump certainly acts on russia's behalf
and acts like russia's
leader not true uh january 2019 eric
swalwell said it's pretty clear
president donald trump is an agent of
russia
not true and swalwell shamelessly
claimed donald trump jr and jared
kushner had an eagerness
and a willingness to work with the
russians during the 2016 election
again it was false um in 2019 he falsely
claimed
this yet again when inquired about
collusion by a reporter
and these baseless attacks were false
yet covered breathlessly by the media
there was no coverage however of
swalwell being the one implicated but
not russia
but china in fact the new york times
website
as of this morning had not one result
for eric swalwell's ties to chinese
spies not
one result and when the swallow story
broke
guess how many minutes of coverage it
got on abc nbc
msnbc and cvs zero
cnn devoted three minutes and 16 seconds
to it um however it was covered
on fox um interesting pre-election and
post-election coverage too
on the hunter biden scandal which was
not covered
at all by many outlets in the lead up to
the election in fact on october 15th
you had a new york times headline that
said trump said to be warned
that he was being con given russian
disinformation over hunter
biden now december 10th just a few
months later
new york times headline investigation of
hunter biden is likely to hang over
biden as he takes
office washington post on october 16th
the headline read the truth behind the
hunter biden non-scandal
now you have the washington post
headline that says this hunter biden tax
probe examining chinese business deals
politico october 19th hunter biden's
story is russian disinformation that's a
favorite dozens of former intel
officials say
false yet again december 2nd now
politico reads justice department's
interest in hunter biden
covered more than taxes really
interesting turn of events
and good for those who covered what was
a story all along and not
russia disinformation isn't it
hypocritical for you to accuse others of
disinformation when you spread it every
day